you would be lucky to make it past 45
years old if you were doing Full Tilt
bodybuilding the entire time you mean
like you'd be dead at 45 potentially
yeah like if you were going hard from
like Teenage Hood to 45 blasting every
single offseason weighing up to 300
pounds you know cutting down to you know
260 270 stand on stage sometimes the
last depends on depends on the height of
the guy whatever I think the top guys at
the sport like I would be impressed if
they came out 45 years old retired and
were like still live the normal duration
of life so let's say that someone hasn't
dropped out at 45 I'm gonna guess in
terms of health health outcomes being
able to live a normal life which isn't
assisted with a ton of drugs on the
outside is at a risk as well if somebody
is Full Tilt maintaining these high body
weights perpetually and doing it for you
know 10 20 years and probably
predisposed yeah like some of these some
guys will drop in their 20s when they
are in this uh in Pro bodybuilding